focus on you
people come and go
if you don't control your mind
someone else will
sometimes the things that break your
heart end up fixing your vision
loneliness is the price you pay when you
start to improve yourself
proud
you survived the days you thought you
couldn't
not everyone will like you
that's life
stop telling people everything
most people don't care
and some secretly want you to fail
be kind
but don't let people use you
it is better to be hated for what you
are
than to be loved for something you are
not
don't go broke trying to impress broke
people
stay away from people who make you feel
lonely
no company is better than a Bad Company
make peace with your past so it won't
screw up the present
don't compare your life to others
you have no idea what their journey is
all about
never underestimate the power of stupid
people
no one is going to figure out your life
it's your responsibility
sometimes you win sometimes you learn
if nobody helps you
do it alone
take your financial life seriously
money is a defense to a lot of
challenges
be selfish with your time
a lot of people don't deserve it
what other people think of you is none
of your business
you can't go back and change the
beginning
but you can start where you are and
change the ending
being alone gives us an opportunity to
reconnect with ourselves
sometimes you need to stop seeing the
good in people and start seeing what
they show you
don't pretend to be better than you are
live life at your own pace
[Music]
life is too short to waste time hating
anyone
your deepest darkest moment may be the
best thing that ever happens to you
Envy is a waste of time
you already have all you need
if you don't ask you don't get
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
if you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
life isn't fair
but it's still good
he who is not courageous enough to take
risks will accomplish Nothing in life
don't trust words
trust actions
do yourself a favor
get rich
life gets easier with money not time
if you can survive your own thoughts
you can survive anything
if they don't appreciate you
they don't deserve you
learn to heal without venting to
everyone
to avoid disappointment a CH nothing
from nobody
everything comes to you at the right
time
be patient and Trust the process
failure is a bruise not a tattoo
avoid gossip at all costs it's poison to
your mind
the root of all suffering is attachment
time always exposes what you truly mean
to someone
stress is temporary but the lessons you
learn from it can last a lifetime
if someone is trying to bring you down
they are already below you
money isn't everything in life
but it can help you solve a lot of
problems
no matter how smart successful and
good-looking you are
nobody likes arrogance
humility is everything
[Music]
don't regret having a good heart
all good things come back and multiply
don't feel guilty for doing what's best
for you
choose your friends wisely
the fastest way to become better is to
surround yourself with better people
be loyal or stay single
that's simple
expect nothing
appreciate everything
be grateful for the little things in
your life to find inner peace
do your best and Trust the process
the harder you work the luckier you will
get
never take anything personally
what others say and do is a projection
of their own reality
be forgiving be understanding
but do not be a fool
never say maybe
if you want to say no
when someone shows you who they are
believe them the first time
your self-respect has to be stronger
than your feelings
don't let success go to your head
don't let failure go to your heart
the best way to respect yourself is to
discipline yourself
if you are a giver
remember to learn your limits because
the takers don't have any
don't waste your time with explanations
people only hear what they want to hear
except criticism but never accept
disrespect
never give up on something you really
want
it's difficult to wait but it's more
difficult to regret
when you are angry
stay silent
you have three choices in life
you can watch things happen make things
happen
or wonder what the hell happened
stay strong
even when things Begin to Fall Apart
you're being judged no matter what
so be who you want to be
you don't have to win every argument
agree to disagree
no regrets just lessons
no worries just acceptance
no expectations
just gratitude
life is too short
the calmer you are the clearer you think
the more you are interested in others
the more interesting they find you
to be interesting be interested
if you are not falling down occasionally
you are just coasting
hatred is a curse that does not affect
the hated
it only poisons the hater
release a grudge as if it was poisoned
we suffer more in imagination than in
reality
people change Love Hurts friends leave
things go wrong
but remember that life goes on
learn to say no without explaining
yourself
be a good person but don't waste your
time proving it
never tell your friends your plans
stop putting too much trust in them
don't let anyone know what you're doing
until it's done
if you want to be trusted be honest
the only person that cares about your
hopes and dreams is you
the only person that is going to make
them happen
is you
forget what hurts you
but never forget what it taught you
mastering others is strength
mastering yourself is true power
even the nicest people have their limits
your direction is more important
than your speed
control your thoughts or your thoughts
will control you
don't over share
privacy is power
don't make a permanent decision based on
temporary emotions
to be the best you must be able to
handle the worst
as long as you are alive
no obstacle is permanent
you'll learn nothing from life if you
think you're right all the time
stay patient
the best things happen unexpectedly
never regret a day in your life
good days give happiness bad days give
experience
worst days give lessons
and best days give memories
life is a one-time offer
use it well
be yourself
people don't have to like you and you
don't have to care
free yourself from society's advice most
of them have no idea
of what they're doing
first it hurts
then it makes you stronger
normalize walking some paths alone
because goals are personal
the family you create is more important
than the family you come from
life is short
live it love is rare
grab it anger is bad dump it
fear is awful
face it
memories are sweet
cherish them